many NHS hospital managers and staff
welcome Savile for his status as a
celebrity and fundraiser they hoped he
would boost staff and patient morale
raise the profile of their organizations
and raise funds for them but his status
as a celebrity and fundraiser whose
presence had been encouraged by senior
managers meant that staff who observed
him behaving inappropriately or who
received reports of him committing
sexual abuses were reluctant to
challenge Savile directly or to escalate
matters to senior managers our
investigations suggest that most NHS
organisations still do not have
adequately explicit and robust processes
for managing their relationships with
celebrities important visitors
fundraisers and donors